la hausse des loyers en province mais
surtout à paris un rapport montre que
les eaux sont souvent exagérées
notamment dans la capitale
la paire rochdi l'iran et la
grande-bretagne rompre leurs relations
diplomatiques en quête d'antenne 2 chez
les musulmans britanniques le tibet se
révolte des morts et des blessés
couvre-feu et loi martiale dans ce pays
occupé par les chinois l'image d'un
autre monde c'est sous le pacifique à
2000 mètres de profondeur grâce au
nautile bonsoir la sphère rush 10,8 et
malheureusement ce n'est pas terminé
dans le monde entier cette affaire
continue de susciter des réactions
souvent violentes et les prises de
position qui ne le sont pas moins
exemple à paris le mac est bien le
magasin pardon parisien virgin une
grande surface du disque a retiré de la
vente
le disque à la de véronique sanson les
galeries lafayette ont décidé de faire
de même toujours les menaces au même
moment le miz intérieur pierre joxe lui
se voulait plus rassurant alors les
faits nouveaux du jour dans cette
affaire hervé brusini il était prévu
depuis longtemps ce conseil de sécurité
mais aujourd'hui le sujet en était tout
trouvé l'affairé rushdie et ses
multiples conséquences diplomatiques
politiques également en matière de
sécurité
sur ce dernier point plusieurs réunions
techniques ont déjà eu lieu au ministère
de l'intérieur dès ce matin pierre joxe
préciser la position du gouvernement sur
d'éventuelles menaces les risques
actuels ne sont pas beaucoup plus grand
que le risque qu'ils ont existé depuis
des années par conséquent il faut pas
s'affoler les mesures de sécurité de
protection contre les attentats sont
permanentes
à certains moments ils sont renforcés
dans un secteur dans un autre mais y'a
pas de quoi il doit pas cesser terrorisé
la france ne sera pas terroriser par des
menaces nouvelles qui prennent d'autres
formes elle est en position de défense
en garde et
pour pas avoir peur et pour cent le plus
grand disquaire des champs-elysées vient
de retirer de ses rayons la chanson à la
de véronique sanson
en coulisses on parle de lettres
anonymes de menaces par téléphone
officiellement il s'agirait de mesures
préventives à quelques pas de là un
autre commerçant lui ne s'est pas laissé
intimider
je crois que c'est une atteinte à la
liberté d'opinion et c'est gran je ne
pense pas avoir à retirer ce 45 tours
en fait les services de police et de
sécurité redoutent surtout des actes
isolés pour l'heure aucune menace
concrète ne semble devoir émaner d'une
organisation liée à un quelconque état
en angleterre ou en allemagne
le danger semble beaucoup plus précis
les autorités françaises elles sont bien
conscientes d'une chose
plus la date de parution du livre
approchera et plus les actes
d'intimidation se multiplieront jean
pierre chevènement ministre de la
défense c'est tout à l'heure des marques
et de laurent fabius
il a prôné la modération dans cette
affaire et a souhaité que la france
garde son sang froid
l'iran a rompu ses relations
diplomatiques avec la grande-bretagne
toujours à cause de cette affaire sans
attendre l'échéance de son ultimatum
c'était ce soir
londres ne veut pas céder sur ses
positions à propos des menaces de mort
proférées sur l'écrivain salman rushdie
cette rupture décidé donc par les
iraniens au parlement est prise avec
flegme du côté britannique de toute
façon dit on là bas il ne peut y avoir
de relations normales avec l'iran tant
que pèse la menace de mort sur l'auteur
des versets sataniques
pas de réaction après cette rupture dans
la communauté musulmane en grande
bretagne il faut rappeler que cette
communauté est presque entièrement
sunnite
elle n'est donc pas adepte de communi
c'est pourtant dans ce pays qu'on avait
pour la première fois brûler le livre de
rushdie c'était il ya deux mois
alors où en est on dans cette communauté
bien philippe harrouard enquêter à
birmingham une ville du centre de
l'angleterre qui compte un million
d'habitants dont cent mille musulmans 1
sur 10
essentiellement des pakistanais et des
indiens reportage
2 les faubourgs de birmingham ici les
musulmans sont presque tous d'origine
pakistanaise des jeunes nés en
grande-bretagne discutent de la sphère
rushdie on sent une volonté énorme de
bien expliquer leur position
les gens doivent comprendre que c'est
une affaire de croyance
on entend dire que notre réaction est
hors de proportion
d'un certain point de vue oui n'est rien
ne sera résolu tant qu'on ne comprendra
pas que nous musulmans avant une
croyance très très fort dans notre
religion
je ne suis pas contre la liberté
d'expression
je suis même pour mais quand il ya un
jure alors toute personne raisonnable
devient contre ce livre est il est
injurieux la sentence de mort de kobenni
on en parle guère
cela n'a rien à voir avec nous répondons
généralement si j'avais une chance de le
tuer moi même je n'hésiterai pas on ne
peut contrôler tout le monde reconnaisse
les chefs religieux très influents dans
leur communauté
mais ils disent aussi que l'islam ne
sépare pas le temporel du spirituel
chaque musulman apprécié personnellement
l'oph ans qui lui est faite à la prière
du vendredi à la grande mosquée il est
demandé aux fidèles de poursuivre leur
protestation pacifiquement car il ya une
volonté de faire baisser la tension
on a apprécié les propos de madame
thatcher reconnaissant que les versets
sataniques était choquant pour les
musulmans mais le pardon éventuelle de
rushdie reste liée au retrait du livre
le pardon est un don de dieu
il pardonne nous aussi c'est indéniable
mais cela dépend également de l'attitude
de l'intéressé s'ils se reposent ou non
s'il persiste à insulter à hull juillet
alors il devient difficile de pardonner
bertrand cisq habite birmingham depuis
30 ans cet ancien enseignant visite
parfois l'épicier mustaq qui fut son
élève la sphère jeudi dit il c'est bien
la preuve que les différentes
communautés qui se côtoient
quotidiennement
en fait si niort la plupart du temps les
musulmans mais aussi les cycles les
indiens les bangladeshis
il reste écarté un ils restent chez eux
dans les gâteaux pour ainsi dire alors
ils n'ont pas paraît-il un grand désir
de se faire intégrer dans notre société
l'université de birmingham abrite un
centre d'études de l'islam de cet
observatoire on apprécie bien
l'évolution de la situation
le message des musulmans commencent à
passer mais cela se fait au détriment de
salman rushdie de plus en plus critiqué
même si tout le monde défend la liberté
d'expression même un artiste doit être
réaliste je crois et doit savoir c'est
qu'il peut provoquer et alors peut-être
là il faudrait plus de compréhension de
la part de ceux qui ont des convictions
assez libéral qu'ils doivent savoir que
ces réactions sont inévitables
ces enfants apprennent par coeur le
corps en trois heures par jour et six
jours par semaine
ils maintiennent vivace la flamme de
l'ifla il leur faudra vivre dans
l'angleterre où ils sont nés comme en
procéderont il beau sujet pour un livre
que personne n'aurait envie d'interdits
enfin pour terminer sur cette affaire et
bien sachez que roland dumas le ministre
français des affaires étrangères a
regretté la rupture des relations
diplomatiques entre la grande bretagne
et l'iran tout de suite cette
information de dernière minute la mort
de roger patrice pelât je viens de
l'apprendre il y à quelques minutes
pendant le reportage de philippe
harrouard alors monsieur roger patrice
pelât vous le savez c'était l'ami du
président mitterrand c'est lui qui
avaient été inculpés il ya quelques
semaines
inculpé de délit d'initié dans la sphère
pechiney on vient de l'apprendre donc il
est décédé tout à l'heure à l'hôpital
américain de neuilly
christophe martet 7 à copains disait de
lui le président de la république
roger patrice pelât faisait partie du
petit cercle d'amis intimes de françois
mitterrand il partageait avec lui sa
promenade de l'après midi les deux
hommes s'étaient connus en allemagne
dans un camp de prisonniers pour se
retrouver ensuite dans le même réseau de
résistance
une amitié de plus de 40 ans entaché
récemment par le scandale pechiney roger
patrice pelât homme d'affaires discret
s'était retrouvé sous les feux de
l'actualité
accusé d'avoir acheté dix mille actions
triangle pour un profit de plus de 2
millions de francs ils avaient été
inculpés il ya trois semaines de recel
de délit d'initié et avait dû payer 4
millions de francs pour rester en
liberté lundi dernier roger patrice
pelât entrée à l'hôpital américain de
neuilly pour un malaise cardiaque
il avait 70 ans au chapitre des affaires
boursières il yal'affaire béguin fait
c'est la nouvelle affaire dont on parle
beaucoup la cob a décidé en effet de
transmettre à la justice son rapport sur
cette affaire
il s'agit de la vente dans des
conditions discutables d'action
montedison par béghin say say they fin
87 une grosse affaire qui n'a pas fini
de faire des vagues
gérard leclerc des transactions en
cascade et à l'arrivée une moins value
de 860 millions au grand dam des petits
actionnaires c'est la sphère béghin-say
point de départ le groupe italien
fairouz immobilise sa filiale béghin-say
pour le rachat d'une société montedison
béghin say en achète 7 % au prix de 1
milliard 910 millions mais le krach
boursier intervient et fait chuter les
cours
et quand bkc revend sa participation de
mondt edison à une autre filiale de
feruzi la transaction s'effectue à un
milliard de francs soit un manque à
gagner de 860 millions
la cob après huit mois d'enquêté relève
des défauts de procédure l'assemblée
générale des actionnaires n'a pas
délibéré de l'opération et elle avoue
son incapacité à apprécier la valeur des
titres échangés des faits qui selon le
rapport pourrait recevoir des
qualifications pénales
autrement dit l'abus de biens sociaux
jean-marc vern le président de béghin
say et banquier réputé proche du rpr
affirme avoir fourni à la cob tous les
éléments d'une opération courante
c'est maintenant la justice de s'y
retrouver dans le dédale des
transactions de béghin say jean-marc
verne le pdg de bkc a décidément
beaucoup d'ennuis s'il est mise en cause
dans le rachat d'une filiale d'havas ce
par l'abbaye cmc sa banque la police
judiciaire vient en effet d'ouvrir une
enquête
et depuis les affaires entre guillemets
et tout le monde est d'accord pour
donner plus de pouvoir à la cob la
commission des opérations de bourse
c'est ce que va faire un projet de loi
présenté demain au conseil des ministres
il s'agit de moraliser le marché
financier avec deux axes principaux
d'abord les op à une folle et réglementé
pour éviter les reds brutaux d'une
entreprise sur une autre et il faut
donner à ceux qui sont attaqués aux
entreprises qui sont attaqués les moyens
de mieux se défendre
l'autre axe et bien c'est celui de la
cob elle-même tout le monde réclamait
plus de pouvoirs
le projet de loi ira même au delà
clerval premiers points du projet de loi
le collège de la corde sera élargie et
plus indépendant il comportera huit
membres au lieu de 5 dont le président
nommés pour six ans et sept
personnalités issues notamment
d'institutions comme le conseil d'état
ou la cour des comptes la coque doit
ensuite être doté d'un véritable pouvoir
d'investigation sous le contrôle du juge
ces enquêteurs pourront ainsi mettre des
biens sous séquestre et même
perquisitionné dans les bureaux comme au
domicile privé
troisième point la cob pourra aller
elle-même devant les tribunaux pour
témoigner et se porter partie civile
enfin la commission des opérations de
bourse devrait disposer d'un pouvoir de
sanction propres
est infligée elle-même si elles le
désirent des amendes allant jusqu'à dix
fois le profit réalisé
voilà il avant de revenir de continuer
le journal je vous rappelle pour
terminer ce chapitre donc des affaires
boursières la nouvelle que je vous
annonçait il ya quelques minutes c'est
la mort de roger patrice pelât qui
avaient été inculpés il ya quelques
semaines dans la sphère pechiney on
appris au courant du début de ce journal
la mort donc de patrice blattes dans un
hôpital à neuilly la suite de
l'actualité avec les loyers combien
payez-vous pour votre loyer alors quelle
que soit la réponse le sujet qui va
suivre vous intéresse bien sûr si l'afer
sort maintenant ce n'est pas tout à fait
un hasard afin d' jours des municipales
quoi qu'il en soit un rapport viennent
d'être rendus publics par le ministère
du logement
et sa conclusion est simple les loyers
augmentent vite en france trop vite
le problème est général à paris comme en
province l'actuel ministre du logement
michel delebarre en a conscience et il a
annoncé que la loi serait bientôt
modifiée
c'est vrai en tout cas c'est à paris que
le dossier le plus crucial c'est là que
les hausses sont les plus fortes surtout
quand il s'agit de renouveler un bail
est bien dans ce cas les propriétaires
exigent parfois des augmentations
insupportable alors pour mettre d'accord
propriétaires et locataires il existe
une commission de conciliation j'en paye
oeufs éclosent barnier ils ont mené leur
enquête avec 4500 litige par an la
commission des loyers de paris traite
plus de trois quarts des conflits en
france est ce leur multiplication par 4
l'an dernier on a refusé en tout cas de
nous laisser filmer à l'intérieur
dehors nous avons retrouvé une locataire
une propriétaire en désaccord la
propriétaire voulait doubler le loyer la
locataire était prête à une hausse de
20% sommes pas d'accord parce que
maintenant
le studio à la plaine monceau à côté du
boulevard mazères un studio qui fait
vannes 6 mètres carrés actuellement 975
francs il veut loyer principal est
charmant sans les champs pour vous le
loyer il est normal où il est
sous-évaluée c'est à dire que tout
dépend si vous aimez de sous-évaluer
parce que le propriétaire ne m'a pas
imputer d'augmentation et vous êtes donc
d'accord pour créer une hausse
je suis d'accord pour qu'il y ait une
résiliation mais très raisonnable est ce
que vous allez la mettre en justice
cette demoiselle ou est-ce que vous
allez rester là si nous n'arrivons pas à
nous mettre d'accord monsieur il est
bien évident que justice que voulez vous
faire
le mois de loyer qui est sous-évalué
alors on parle des propriétaires qui
surévaluent je prends deux manches sinon
avec un inverse
je pense que cette loi me nourrit elle
elle applique à beaucoup de confusion et
les professeurs serez valu leur
appartement parce qu'ils se basent sur
des loyers restant si la loi maintenant
demain vous oblige à voir des loyers
limité de gens auraient la possibilité
de ne plus louer mon studio c'est tout
il faut je ferai appel d'avoir un studio
vide que louer dans ces conditions des
logements retirés de la location comme
sous la loi trio c'est un des risques
d'une limitation de la liberté des
propriétaires envisagées par le
gouvernement pour corriger les effets
pervers de la loi méhaignerie le
gouvernement pourtant ne peut rester
sans réagir à paris où des milliers de
locataires ont dû accepter des hausses
en moyenne de 1000 francs par mois les
anges d'ariane une grande précision pour
le 29e tir réussi de la fusée européenne
c'était le onzième succès consécutif
ariane donc à mise en orbite deux
satellites un japonais un européen tout
s'est passé avec succès c'était la nuit
dernière au même moment les américains
ont quelques problèmes avec leurs
navettes patrice pollet
retardés de six jours quatre pour cause
de grève deux pour raisons techniques
ariane à zéro heure 29 heure de paris a
donc quitté son pas de tir dans un ciel
bien dégagé un beau décollage suivi
d'une mission en vite parfaite des deux
satellites embarqué le premier européen
meteosat le deuxième japonais de
télévision directe des japonais enfin
heureux il faut dire que depuis deux ans
il attend dès cet instant à l'origine
leurs satellites devait être en effet
lancé par une navette pour arianespace
la précision du tir de cette nuit
confirment la performance du lanceur
européen
de leur côté les américains ont quelques
problèmes avec leur navette discovery
une navette qui devait décoller dans 48
heures et qui pour le moment est cloué
au sol un composant électrique important
est défaillant il est mis en fonction au
moment de la séparation des booster son
remplacement devrait être terminé demain
et si tout va bien
discovery pourrait décoller la semaine
prochaine pour la 29e mission les
municipales j - 5 ce soir nous allons à
nîmes c'est la ville dont jean bousquet
le maire sortant il mène une liste
d'opposition mais bien sûr il est très
attaqué sur sa gauche
nîmes c'est une ville qui a sans doute
retrouver une conscience municipal si
l'on peut dire
depuis le drame qui à l'automne dernier
a dévasté la fit et souvenez vous
c'était les terribles inondations
véronique sainte olive dominique merlin
au commencement il y avait ni mille
emile jourdan 75 ans trois fois maire
trois fois député et conseiller général
a incarné jusqu'en 83,1 communisme enfin
ses propres couleurs en 83 la gauche
s'effondre jean bousquet apparentée udf
et telles hummer c'est la fin du règne
de mimile et le début de l'ère du pdg de
cacharel un gestionnaire bâtisseur le
parti socialiste se cherche et cherche
son leader après l'échec de georgina
dufoix
c'est un nouveau qui descend dans
l'arène françois brugairolles il a tout
à prouver
et puis il ya juste cinq mois une
inondation catastrophique transforme
nîmes en ville sinistrée
des millions de dégâts des milliers de
sans abri jean bousquet tient bon la
barre
mais aujourd'hui la catastrophe
permettent à chacun de prendre ses
marques et nos jours dans ranime les
vieilles connaissances et période
électorale oblige ils attisent les
vieilles querelles j'ai aussi et s'est
comporté comme aux devoirs se serait
comporté tous les maires qu'ils soient
de droite ou gauche dans des sacs
besaces pareil je crois aussi qu'il a
utilisé un peu faut bien le dire
l'alchimiste pour
améliorer son image de marque françois
brugairolles entrée tardivement en
campagne s'affrontent pour se faire
connaître tant que ville de droite
effectivement il y anime à deux vitesses
à nîmes qui souffre et à nîmes qui fait
la fête
ce que je peux reprocher aussi de très
forts à jean bousquet c'est le nîmes
médiatique le nîmes des grands coups le
nîmes de la couverture des arènes de
nîmes du grand stade
ce sont de belles réalisations mais qui
ne correspondent pas à la réalité ni
moss les critiques de ses adversaires
laissent jean bousquet de marbre le
maire sortant a réveillé la ville son
bilan et son meilleur argument électoral
anime aujourd'hui est une ville qui
s'est réveillée de droite je sais pas
j'essaie d'appliquer une politique
libérale que tout le monde puisse
s'exprimer et entreprendre maintenant
sur un pca de droite oui mais vous
connaissez mon slogan c'est ni de gauche
ni de droite
dimanche il n'y aura sans doute pas de
suspense jean bousquet devrait frôler la
majorité absolue il ne marchandera pas
les voix du front national
l'enjeu est à gauche qui du pc ou du ps
est aujourd'hui en tête à nîmes
seuls les chiffres apporteront la
réponse
le tibet le tibet qui se révoltent le
tibet c'est un pays de montagnes occupée
par les chinois depuis l'année dernière
les violences reviennent régulièrement
cette semaine il est encore eu des morts
à lhassa la loi martiale a été instaurée
et le couvre feu décrété jérôme baugnies
d'abord une poignée de moines tibétains
arborant le drapeau de l'indépendance
quelques rues plus loin des centaines de
manifestants attaquant un commissariat
de police
la télévision chinoise n'a pas cherché à
dédramatiser les événements de l'aca qui
ont fait l'ouverture de son journal hier
soir les commentaires de la
présentatrice sont très critiques à
l'égard des séparatistes criant selon
ses propres termes des slogans
réactionnaire elle reconnaît que la
police a tiré sur la foule
après plusieurs sommations mais affirme
que la situation est maintenant bien
maîtrisé en fait les rares témoignages
en provenance de la capitale tibétaine
attestent du contraire
les émeutes se poursuivent maintenant
depuis trois jours et les autorités ont
été finalement contrainte de décréter la
loi martiale et le couvre-feu à partir
de ce soir
trente ans après la guerre de mars 59 la
fuite du dalaï lama vers l'inde et
l'annexion du tibet par la chine pékin
n'a toujours pas réussi à étouffer la
culture tibétaine langue chinoise
obligatoire dans l'enseignement
secondaire hôpitaux réservé implantation
massive de ressortissants chinois n'ont
fait que redoubler les réactions
religieuse et nationaliste l'aca est
divisée en deux communautés rester bien
distinctes et hostile qui s'affrontent
régulièrement depuis un an et demi
pourtant de son exil le dalaï lama a
fait un pas vers une solution politique
en acceptant de renoncer à
l'indépendance pour une simple autonomie
mais pékin n'a pas répondu à cette
proposition et les militaires chinois
attendent avec appréhension la date du
10 mars 30e anniversaire de la
répression sanglante du soulèvement
tibétain
les autres informations du jour c'est en
bref et en images avec éric perrin
roger tamraz affirme qu'il sera libre
d'ici 24 à 48 heures après l' agence de
presse a fait l'homme d'affaires
libanais dont le nom a été cité à
plusieurs reprises dans la sphère
pechiney aurait été enlevé il ya
quelques jours à beyrouth
il semble que de rançon était est versé
à ses ravisseurs
ceux-ci agirait pour le compte de
créanciers lésés par la récente faillite
de la banque libanaise al mashreq que
dirige et roger tamraz
deux morts 21 blessés dans l'explosion
d'une voiture piégée à beyrouth ouest
l'attentât a eu lieu en plein secteur
musulman au coeur du dispositif de
quadrillage par l'armée syrienne
ils marquent un regain de tensions entre
les communautés chrétienne et musulmane
et
un jeune palestinien de 18 ans tué par
l'armée israélienne dans les territoires
occupés
une vingtaine d'autres blessés le
couvre-feu qui avait été levé hier a
finalement été rétabli à naplouse en
cisjordanie les palestiniens ont lancé
un appel à la grève générale pour demain
et après-demain la libération hier en
israël
224 détenus palestiniens n'a donc pas
ramener le calme comme l'espéraient les
autorités israéliennes la france qui rit
la france qui pleure hier c'était soleil
partout ou presque aujourd'hui c'était
trombe et des luges pour tout le monde
ou presque dans quelques minutes
josé blanc la pierre nous dira que
demain ça ira beaucoup mieux
le résultat en tout cas en montagne
c'est le même risque d'avalanche encore
emmanuel vanier rejet mature et ont
enquêté dans le massif du mont blanc
les spécialistes lors on expliqué sur le
terrain la réalité du danger
pendant une semaine les secouristes ont
fouillé l'avalanche sous lui mètre de
neige
un jeune suisse alpiniste expérimenté il
était parti sur cet itinéraire de haute
montagne
malgré les très mauvaises conditions
météo une coulée de neige l'a emporté
les sauveteurs ont retrouvé son corps
cet après midi il avait 22 ans
des accidents très fréquent ce moment
hors piste après les fortes chutes de
neige de la semaine dernière
hier à tignes encore deux morts dont un
professionnel de la montagne le risque
majeur
les plaques à vent des couches de neige
fraîche déposé sur une sous couche très
instable elles sont la plupart du temps
invisible le seul poids du skieur peut
déclencher la rupture de la cohésion des
couches et c'est l'avalanche
c'est très très dangereux parce que ces
plaques à vent subsiste très longtemps
même en cas de nouvelles chutes de neige
elles peuvent rester dessous les
derniers événements ont montré que les
gens ne suivaient pas vraiment les
conseils de sécurité dépisteurs des
gendarmes secouristes alors c'est un
petit peu dommage et malheureusement ils
l'ont payé très fort il faut respecter
les consignes des services de cycle de
dix pistes sécurité des pistes sont des
gens qui sont très compétents qui
déclenche les avalanches au moyen
d'explosifs pour justement sécuriser les
pistes de pau les skieurs il faut
respecter leur travail
il faut rester sur les pistes balisées
un autre piège à temps les skieurs
hors-piste de la vallée blanche
les crevasses la couche de neige fraîche
les dissimule les ponts de neige sont
très fragiles il y a quelques jours un
guide est tombé ici il est grièvement
blessé dans toutes les stations le
drapeau à damier a été hissé il signifie
danger
le hors piste est vivement déconseillé
la sécurité imposent de ne pas
s'éloigner des pistes balisées
le gang des mercedes a été démantelée
voiture volée vrai faux documents et
revente en bonne et due forme c'était la
méthode une dizaine de personnes
inculpées et et italiens pour la plupart
ils auraient détourné pour 30 millions
de francs de mercedes agnès poirier de
patrice voler les voitures volées
grosses cylindrées mercedes de
préférence retrouvait ici dans ce garage
toulonnais toute la côte d'azur était
passé au peigne fin
cible privilégiée des voleurs les
touristes étrangers
une nouvelle plaque d'immatriculation
une nouvelle carte grise est ici au
mondial garage les voitures devenait
italienne en toute discrétion car si le
gérant du garage est en prison son chef
d'atelier n'a rien remarqué au courant
de rien pour moi c'était des achats et
des ventes de voitures complètement tout
à fait régulière avec des vrais de des
papiers en règle
bonnier d'itron les soi-disant voitures
italiennes quitté toulon pour poitiers
où elle était tout à fait normalement
des douanes et dernière étape
sa mort dans ce garage de la banlieue
parisienne les marchés des cds vendus
entre 300 et 400 mille francs
munis de cartes grises en règle c'est un
trophée très important il faut savoir
qu'actuellement
l'enquète a permis de
le mettre à jour une centaine de
véhicules volés mais ça c'est la partie
visible de l'iceberg si je puis dire et
donc étant donné qu'il s'agissait
essentiellement de véhicules mercedes de
haut de gamme
en l'état actuel on peut chiffrer le
préjudice à 3 milliards de centimes
le trafic était bien rodé les voitures
s'écouler sans problème depuis 2 ans
vingt-deux personnes ont été
interpellées dix sont ce soir sous les
verrous en sport d'abord la composition
de l'équipe de france de foot 7 ecosse
france c'est demain soir mercredi voici
donc la sélection de michel platini pour
ce match important qui compte
vous le savez pour la qualification pour
la coupe du monde alors à noter que
platini n'a pas va essayer plutôt en
attaque
la combinaison papin xuereb c'est
nouveau ça vient de sortir et puis il ya
aussi la première sélection du sochalien
thierry laurey et puis en cyclisme paris
10 victoires de l'étape du jour pour le
belge de wild qui avait déjà gagné hier
c'est le sprinteur belge donc qui
endosse le maillot de leader celui que
vous avez vu c'est laurent fignon qui
aujourd'hui dans l'étape a été obligé
d'abandonner à cause des ennuis de santé
le cinéma africain il a montré sa bonne
santé au festival de ouagadougou
le grand prix a été remporté par un film
qui s'appelle héritage d'afrique
un film ghanéen le cinéma africain
depuis son premier long métrage qui
datent de 66 se bagarre sur tous les
fronts avec un choix particulier pour
les problèmes de société
jean jacques dufour qui était au
festival de ouagadougou s'est attaché à
la place de la femme dans le cinéma
américain
ça tombe bien demain 8 mars c'est la
journée de la femme le festival de
ouagadougou est l'une des rares
occasions pour les africains de voir
leur propre production puisque ce
continent est privé de ses propres
images colonisé qu'il est par les films
étrangers
quoi qu'il en soit cette année l'image
forte renvoyé par les réalisateurs
africains ceux plus la condition
féminine au centre des débats
l'excision le mariage forcé et la
polygamie
j'ai décidé de prendre une 6e et pousse
quoi six femmes pour vous c'est c'est
complètement incongru c'est dégueulasse
c'est humiliant c'est ça le dérange
devrait pas voir ça les matches ont du
souci à se faire car annie brigitte
jeune actrice ivoirienne et vedette de
bal poussière film plein d'humour nous a
confié lors d'un défilé de mode organisé
dans le grand hôtel de ouaga qu'elle
n'était pas tout seul à penser cela
la nouvelle génération inspire à autre
chose qu'à devenir par exemple la
sixième femme d'un homme surnommé demi
dieu parce qu'après dieu le chef du
village c'est lui la semaine se compose
de sept jours et six avec six épouses
mais je réserverai une nuit à chacune
est le 7e jour cela réservé à celles
croatie se faire remarquer pendant la
semaine
la tradition comme ça en afrique on ne
peut pas s'en passer mais de plus en
plus il faut arriver à éliminer
effectivement l'acromégalie castetbon la
vie depuis un prix devient de plus en
plus difficile
vous voulez éliminer parce que vous
pensez que ça coûte trop cher ah oui si
ça coûte très cher personnel moi je
garde le cap et d'une forme bal
poussière vilipende également la
soumission totale l'amour oui mais à
certaines conditions
je vais te dire comment ça se passe si
tu as envie tu me dis que là si je veux
je te dis rebelote mais si je ne veux
pas je dis j'ai passe à l'est quand on
est bien éduqué c'est comme ça en bas
c'est que cette façon de ça la nouvelle
façon
vous trouvez que les hommes africains
sont macheist mais tous les hommes sont
macheist qu'ils soient africains au ans
au machisme les européens déguise plus
mais tous les hommes sur la chaîne signe
de l'évolution des moeurs cette scène où
annie brigitte joue presque nu une chope
pratiquement plus les spectateurs
africain il y a encore quelques années
une tenue pareil lui aurait valu d'être
considéré comme une prostituée
la femme africaine évoluer magie stupa
les hommes devront suivre
et puis à propos cinéma cette bonne
nouvelle à propos de camille claudel qui
vous le savez au césar avait été
consacré meilleur film de l'année et
bien depuis ces récompenses camille
claudel a triplé ses entrées in dans les
salles par rapport à la semaine dernière
à l'issue d'une campagne de 11 plonger
dans le pacifique le nautile le
sous-marin vedette de l'ifremer rapporte
de nombreuses images d'un monde étrange
vous allez voir c'est absolument
étonnant un monde où les êtres se rit
des formes et des couleurs cela malgré
les formidable pression qui règne à 2000
mètres sous l'eau invitation au voyage
patrick esther je ne sais pas à quoi
ressemble les extraterrestres
peut-être simplement à cet être étrange
sorte de palmier rouge accrochée à un
rochus couleurs vives là où les yeux
n'existe pas là où la lumière ne
parvient jamais fossile vivant qui n'a
pas évolué depuis des millions d'années
poissons oiseaux
le bateau russe nageoires en forme de
trains d'atterrissage qui marche avec
2000 mètres dos au dessus de la tête
le poulpe qui veut se faire aussi bon qu
une citrouille équipe arabe devant les
caméras du nautile avant de se
métamorphoser en soleil
les scènes intimes des abysses où
l'homme devient voyeur le temps d'un
projecteur qui perce les ténèbres
éternelles
voilà avant de refermer complètement ce
journal je reviens sur la principale
information de cette édition que je vous
donnais tout à l'heure tout au début du
journal la mort de patrice pelât patrice
pelât vous le savez c'est cette et l'ami
du président mitterrand c'est l'homme
qui avaient été inculpées notamment dans
la sphère pechiney hervé brusini on
vient justement d'apprendre que le
président françois mitterrand a tenu à
les rendre hommage un dernier hommage à
son ami patrice pelât il est en ce
moment même semble-t-il à l'hôpital
américain patrice pelât vous le voyez là
on le savait très affecté après son
inculpation le 20 février dernier on
savait aussi qu'il est très conscient à
l'hôpital américain ça se passait sept
jours précisément après son inculpation
il était entré dans cet établissement
pour une embolie pulmonaire
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il s'est
effondrée brutalement dans sa chambre il
était debout frappé par un arrêt
cardiaque
nous nous étions informés hier à peine
sur l'état de santé de monsieur roger
patrice pelât et son entourage nous
avait dit cela va mieux il semble donc
que monsieur peule a été victime d'une
mort subite
dès 22h hervé je pense que nous aurons
les premières réactions des premiers
témoignages après la disparition de cet
homme compagnon d'infortuné commise est
président qui était âgé de 70 ans
merci à hervé voilà cette fois fin de ce
journal alors vous rendez vous tout de
suite la météo avec josé blanc lapierre
qui annonce que le temps va s'améliorer
aussitôt après les dossiers de l'écran
présentés par paul amar avec un thème
brûlant les prisons et puis j'en profite
justement un petit peu trop tôt pour
vous présenter
l'excellent document que vient de
publier paul amar c'est une enquête dans
une ville moyenne de province avec deux
provinces bien sûr avec l'oeil aiguë la
journaliste politique scènes de la vie
de province est le titre de ce livre la
dernière édition ce sera 23h45 avec
philippe gassot et puis demain matin
télématin nous avait laissés coop
excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
20 heures